et alors et alors moi non plus j'ai pas
d'âge et je vais pas chez le monde
depuis quelques temps vous pouvez vous
laisser aller à tous vos fantasmes avec
le téléphone rose
osez le sexe par téléphone 200 francs la
minute à nos sos désir harriman biquet
elle faisait désirer tuheiava la plus
coquine à plus sensuelle de toutes les
réponses 2 me dire tu es bien tomber toi
il va le bata plaisir qu'elle est un
type de femme grande le plomb des trucs
plutôt charles vous pouvez vous permet à
1115 où on this correspond un téton tu
as tu peux pas savoir
amat 72 96 60 96 les cheveux couleur
senador embauche à mourir tu vois quoi
une belle bouche mais indigent
j'ai une belle bouche ces objets balle
bouge c'est ce que je suis en train de
faire tout de suite c'est parce que
chacun de ses membres n'ont pas tu vois
pas en train de manger ton petit corps
vous tombe pas on me sens bien
ouais ça chouette un élu pour mon petit
quizz un vrai petit pour les bretons
étaient vraiment vous dis moi mon
week-end au stade de la conversation là
on en a mis sept enfants et vous
poursuivre en arène comme tu veux je
préfère vous appelez le mois prochain
mais j'attendrai ce pour quoi oui
d'accord et c'est un peu cher mais alors
qu'ils avertissent
[Musique]
c'est marrant je sais tout comme son
mari plus blanc que le mien c'est normal
j'utilise le savant du cas pour le sar
en garde les parents qui dérape
vous savez depuis peu fr3 est devenue la
chaîne de la culture aussi nous avons le
plaisir de vous présenter à partir
d'aujourd'hui une nouvelle émission
intitulée un acteur lit en hauteur
aujourd'hui joseph bouillon lit proust
isabelle tourna la tête
elle souffre est abominablement la mer
était démontée
c'était comme si on lançait dans l'école
[Musique]
voilà je suis avec le professeur dit var
à bord d'un engin très très très
spacieux femme est contente de mon jeu
de mots là un professeur de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit de pitau numéro tonnes et tous
numéros de u2 navette une navette une
navette qui marche comment un mec qui
marchent agace espèces de râles hausse
découle évidemment à gaz butane à gaz
propane comme témoin ce terrain nous
allons partir dans l'espace professeur
thetford-mines
on voit pas sur le coeur mais nous
sommes déjà dans l'espace mais je vous
rassure mais regardez mais regardez
enfin j'aperçois j'aperçois nous les
toits des berges et gnagnagna oui je
pensais en bourse à l'ours polaire donc
en fumée
avant de décoller il faut que j'aille
chercher les professions bush
informez vous n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
me ramener s'il vous plaît un sandwich
au jambon et canettes de bière merci
professeur pektas j'étais persuadé qu'on
était dans l'espace
aujourd'hui
économique et social l'été 1985
aura-t-il était propice pour tous les
hôteliers qui vivent sur le littoral
excusez moi petit problème
nick a
à
ah ah
économique et social l'été 1985
or at il été bénéfique pour tous les les
hôteliers de du littoral provence alpes
côte d'azur c'est une question qu'on est
appelé à se poser à se poser
dynastie des mimiques
dans le cas où vous pendriez en cours de
route cette grande saga historique
voici un résumé des épisodes précédents
l'histoire se déroule dans une
principauté imaginaire situé à 30
kilomètres de nice à crapaud quelle
jolie frappe au jour le crapaud quel
joli jeu lui faire un bisou
bonjour le prince bienfaitrice en
m'embrassant tu a rompu le sort qu'on
avait jeté sur mon berceau
quel est ton est beauté moi je fais
partie de la dynastie des ebooks
là tu vas si des boucs quel est ton
prénom nadine j'ai bien connu ta mère
ça s'appelle un coup de foudre le prince
lui l'ue va immédiatement demandé la
main de la belle nadine amouk à son père
le roi devra partir pour jérusalem
j'ai mokhtar tu devras me ramener 2 kg
de boudin blanc dès que le prince lui
par pour jérusalem ne dîne se fait
enlever par le pesq à tort et son fidèle
akbar jolie maclou ils l'entraînent dans
son par m aux confins du désert
[Musique]
musique
il
pendant ce temps lui arrive à jérusalem
et rencontres kasseem jr boudin archi un
boudin blanc
[Musique]
achat sous les voûtes bien comme ça
pendant ce temps le pesq à tort commence
à saturer de la belle n'a dit ni mook et
essaye de la revendre le temps chant
brûle la gandoura et brûlis jeune et
plein ébat beau jeu c'est mon coeur je
peux plus tendus l'ouvrier france et
blanc de préférence je peux plus je peux
plus je fais quelque chose tout de suite
à l'eau les bars à sion paris bien
passement les petites annonces le prince
lui oublie nadine amouk dans les bras
des chats écrasés
c'est toi la phrase qui tirait bien
celle de bachelard si je trouve plus con
que moi je veux tu pourras c'est tout ce
passe comme envers le disait un plus con
que toi on meurt je peux pas je peux pas
vivre avec toi je peux plus rester avec
la barre 1
alors je me casse je retourne chez
kassim avec lui au moins je pouvais
discuter avec lui au moins je pouvais
philosopher eh ben ça tombe bien parce
que je commençais aussi en avoir marre
claque
aïcha écrasé l'entente serait un hadji
bon d'accord ça voulait pas aux mots -
l'embrasser elle pensait à la décoration
de la maison celle là va chez ta mère
tiens elle n'aura pas eu le temps
d'aller chez sa mère à moins qu a quand
même des noms prédestinés elle tient à
riesch a écrasé sa écrasé voilà c'est
tout d'où l'expression populaire mais
pas dans la suite qu'elle fit un pierre
berger allemand est à son tour mordu
pour nadine berger quel joli berger
allemand
je vais faire un petit bonjour les
bergers allemands
bonjour et belle enfant tu sais comme
invité exactement les garder ta maison
est pâtent hamelin ouamane le décor est
planté
les personnages aussi où vous êtes
maintenant fin prêt à suivre la suite de
cette grande saga la dynastie des ebooks
ne ratez pas dès samedi prochain
votre grand feuilleton quelques
dromadaires la dynastie des ebooks
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
vous êtes tous là pour rigoler édité en
france ont failli beaucoup d'impôts mais
qu'est ce qu'on rigole
vous allez l'avoir la dernière alors
justement là voilà qu'arrive l'histoire
de deux chinois de chinois qui marchent
dans une rue
et alors nos deux chinois arrivent en
sens inverse
n'est ce pas et arrive au moment où ils
vont se croiser et à ce moment précis où
ils se croisent des choix regard de
l'autre et lui dit salut maurice
s'allume au rif
salut maury
mathieu regarda le mur
[Musique]
tous à mende
quand les étoiles eux
pour eux
paris
[Musique]
g
je
[Musique]
les amis célèbres la véritable histoire
d'amour
césar et marc antoine et aubin on va
plus
j'ai appris que des revues césar
aujourd'hui je t'interdis leur voix j'ai
le droit d'accueillir ces armes ont pas
laissé le clairement dit je te perdu de
revoir ses sorts toi mais jaloux et la
shoah
[Musique]
c'est ça
mon césar marc-antoine européens
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir voici
l'émission humoristique d'affaires 3 et
wii avec une première histoire
l'histoire de deux chinois qui se rend
compte alors que la seule émission qui
dérègle même votre téléviseur des
membres semaine la monnaie j'ai pas de
monnaie de la monuc vitamines
depeche mode et parfois avec
[Musique]
voilà notre mission
nous allons nous quitter mais nous
allons nous retrouver la semaine
prochaine samedi prochain ne manquez pas
notre nouvelle émission tous les samedis
sur fr3 et je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
[Musique]
c'est vous le hasard surgi en force à
l'échelle macroscopique jeu ça va être
ça que tu me dis parce que la tra
standaard n'est possible que dans les
systèmes où l équilibre oui je suis
alors oui c'est moi tu vas bien tu as
fait bon voyage
oui je suis content voyage au shérif
qu'est-ce que je suis contente de temps
en temps tu sais je t'aime je pense à
toi sans âge
aussi je pense à toi sans arrêt tu
marques tu me manques je suis dit qu'est
ce que tu fais quoi manger
en ce moment je suis en train de
regarder les photos de toi et des petits
je suis emporté
ne me dis pas tu emporte une photo de
man et des enfants oui tu es merveilleux
tu me reproches et ensuite tu vois moi
j'ai une surprise pour tous les faits
sur brit cvg mes grands mères dans tera
10 puis série j'ai mes grands mères dans
ta valise ca le petit cochon ordures
c'est le marché dit sexuelle de grands
dégueulasse mines
il ya une liaison étroite entre
l'aléatoire et irréversible invité de ce
magazine d ar pieri car aviateurs
artisans il vient de réaliser son
premier film thierry car mon jour
pourquoi film sur les ulm
donc quand je vais car vous êtes
empêcher un passionné des ulm
ça ne date pas d'hier cette élection
écoutez le mieux je crois c'est
peut-être qu'on voit en images ce que
vous avez réalisé un petit extrait tout
de suite du film de pierre ricard une
bud peuple-belge une journée que qq qui
se sont déroulés coupe ce qui est beau
film le coucou coucou on prend on a fait
comme ça y est tout le monde tout le
monde je vous remercie de votre
attention
à demain la semaine prochaine les amours
célèbres ou la véritable histoire
d'amour du lys et de pénélope
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ulysse rentrant de son long périple
n'avait dans ses oreilles que le chant
des sirènes
si votre femme vous emmerde
faites comme moi fait le coup des
sirènes c'est facile et ça marche à tous
les coups
[Musique]
c'est l'humoriste bonjour dit non
vraiment vous n'avez rien monsieur que
vous déjà des formules être chaud oui
nom prénom âge et dernier emploi alors
fait chaud jol est chaud pour le 22 ans
vous mettez 22 ans ahmed dernières
emploient péripatéticienne en trois mots
péripatéticienne dans votre secteur
lorelei avec ap le marché complètement
saturé n'ont rien du tout vous étiez
vous j'ai fait sur les grands boulevards
j'avais une très très bonne petite
clientèle fumeuse et très bon mois non
je rien du tout ça fait comme une dame
vous avez arrêté de travailler
ça fait un petit mois quoi au juste il
avait dû perdre la main a pas du tout à
ça j'ai pas perdu la main monsieur tout
le gard entre nous j'ai travaillé au
noir je ne parle pas de racisme mission
nadine pe
tout le monde a droit au travail j'ai
rien rue
non tout est bloqué là c'est peut-être
un truc la rue car banal dans le
quartier des fonctionnaires à la carte
et les fonctionnaires quelle horreur
monsieur j'ai commencé au quartier les
fonctionnaires j'estime qu'à l'heure
actuelle je tue devenue une
professionnelle une méritante et je
tiens évoluer dans mon travail c'est pas
la peine de regarder julien gauze
je suis désolé en prématurée des mois
non je vous en prie faites un petit
espoir et des mois oui semaines voyagent
oui je suis prête à déménager s'il le
faut je peux peut-être vous aider j'ai
mon frère mon frère a déjà fait pas mal
de choses pour certaines de vos
collègues
c'est évidemment moyennant commission je
suis prête à tout va prosper est dans
les parages on espère bien voir ici
c'est la nouvelle pour tanger mois pour
avoir de beaux cheveux
j'utilise mejor mèche d'or est un
shampoing 100% naturel fait à base
d'oeufs de guano d'excréments de poule
mais je dors h emploie 100 % naturel la
dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine amouk et le prince lui
victime des sortilèges de merlin le
chanteur cherche une solution pour
retrouver leur apparence normale je peux
pas rester comme ça bouge pas on va
aller voir l'effet dé foot et je crois
que c'est fermé mardi
c'était bien on va quand même essayer
l'engin vers hélas rien n'a rien
mesdemoiselles
nous allons aujourd'hui aborder la leçon
27 chapitres 49/100 les doigts de ton et
maman sera propre
je compte sur votre vigilance le
syndicat a toujours raison le sluc a
toujours raison qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous savez pas lire
c'est fermé le mardi
il faut toujours obéir aux syndicats
vous nous écoutez une crotte
il ne faut pas oublier de payer ses
cotisations au syndicat nous pour voir
les deux pays cotisations syndicales et
paulino reset ces thèmes où vous me
reprenait tout ça plus fort s'il vous
plaît il ne faut pas pauline il ne faut
pas payer ses cotisations au syndicat du
silence on veut retrouver notre
apparence à vous voulez transformer au
oui oui transformer nous allez les
filles le sens vannes chaque chapitre 42
m'étonnerait pas qu'elle l'ait fait
exprès je les connais
[Musique]
monsieur charles tricot l'eau un des
chefs de l'opposition nationale n'y va
pas de main morte
lors du dernier congrès de son parti
il accuse notre corporation de
complaisance voire de complicité totale
vis-à-vis du pouvoir en place
eh bien monsieur charles tricot l'eau
puisque vous accuser directement notre
rédaction
je vais vous répondre au nom de tous mes
confrères nous nous les journalistes de
gauche
nous savons ce qu'est l'objectivité nous
savons ce que l'indépendance d'esprit
indépendance objectivité de vous ignorer
complètement vous hein vous la droite a
pointé par le comité des forges et les
nervis de la cia mort mon renard vie
fasciste non au grand capital
vive l'indépendance d'esprit vive la
liberté de la presse
vive la gauche unie vive monsieur le
ministre de l'information
nous avons le pouvoir et nous garderons
[Musique]
danse
mais là
bon depuis cinq ans j'utilise de saint
bon point de presse que le savons et
nous je le trouve plus de brumath beau
et aussi folle à poney
ça fait dix ans ça fait dix ans que je
travaille à l'usiné de savon mon minou
et je peux vous assurer que les les
savons nous nous sont vraiment des
savons pur chat en plus il est 100% pur
cher
[Musique]
du sénat
c'est à la portée de tous tout dépend
évidemment de la direction d'acteurs par
exemple le dialogue entre ces deux
personnages as-tu pensé à acheter le
pain oui mais j'ai oublié de prendre le
sel c'est tout chéri que la charcuterie
d'à côté fermé non c'est dommage le
boudin il a été très bon on peut prendre
des formes diverses selon le metteur en
scène à la manière de cluj
[Musique]
oui je vais prendre le sel en fait c'est
tu chéris que la charcuterie d'à côté
fermé c'est dommage le boudry ne
l'appui
pensez à acheter le pain mais je pense
acheter le pain mais j'ai complètement
oublié de prendre celle du shérif que
l'achat petite fille d'à côté le projet
à la manière de jean luc godard dû
penser à prendre le bain oui mais j'ai
oublié de prendre le cerf au fait tu
sais tu que la charcuterie d'à côté
fermé c'est dommage mais voudrait
tellement samedi
achetez nos ben oui
j'ai oublié de prendre le sel
[Musique]
en fait la charcuterie d'à côté fermé
le good eye atp
[Musique]
as-tu pensé l'attendre le point pris
mais j'ai oublié de prendre le cei a à
cet effet ricochet spiteri des
territoriaux comme le bouddha étaient si
bons
[Musique]
à
tu as pensé comme le satellite ka
chapitre il a coûté personnellement j'ai
cette version là qu'on préfère
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire dit fr3 à
marseille 2 à l'airé grassi 13008
marseille on tiendra compte de vos
réactions
peut-être
le sport on voit cevital indispensable
indispensable à mon équilibre
j'ai besoin bien sûr d'éliminer mais
j'ai besoin surtout souvent de nous
remettre en forme et pour nous remettre
en forme je me pique à l'eau de javel
pour l'oublier celui que j'aime comme ça
pourrait ici madame thatcher
vous avez téléphoné pour dire qu'on
m'avait volé la rivière de diamants
figurez vous que j'ai la preuve
mais c'est trop tard madame tas de gens
oui vous savez votre choix
l'arabe enfin lille immigrés quoi oui ça
a été un peu long mais il a tout avoué
oui elle ne nous fait plus de souci rend
très bien chez vous on s'occupe du reste
c'est très bien car ses pairs à
l'occasion du 400e anniversaire de la
construction de la tour de pise
un événement en mondiovision que nous
vous proposons de vivre pour cela et
sans plus tarder nous allons rejoindre
là-bas notre envoyé spécial
regardez et oui en direct depuis la tour
de pise
puisque aujourd'hui nous fêtons un
anniversaire la tour de pise à 400 ans
au départ une érection difficile une
réaction compliqué puisque érection sur
des marécages et cette élection continue
aujourd'hui encore à nous poser des
problèmes puisque elle s'enfonce elle
s'en fout
[Musique]
le guen
gaudin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais tous go
[Musique]
ok
ghoga
tous
[Musique]
et
vous connaissez les trois choses qui
prouve que jésus-christ était juif
premièrement il avec jusqu'à 30 ans avec
sa mère
deuxièmement il était persuadé que sa
mère était vierge
troisièmement ce maire l'a toujours pris
pour un dieu la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents c'est la
princesse nadine amouk est acceptée dans
le clan demeure un des bois avec lui
elle se met au travail
puis elle est pauvre mais d'abord les
trouver
[Musique]
bon
voilà
non
la bourse a ou la vie voilà qui est bien
est ce que je suis content bien toi
qu'on les cherche ses mots on en parle
beaucoup de ces nouveaux pauvres mais on
les voit pas souvent nouveau pauvre
petit robert nouveau port apparaissent
en général au cours d'une crise
économique
voir page 30 tout de même ça suffit le
dico en route pour de nouvelles
aventures mais avant ça suffit regarde
là bas encore notre endroit j'étais
encore on va y aller tout de suite lui
donne au dîner j'ai l'impression que
morceau était trop gros là je connais
depuis longtemps je connais leur budget
c'est vraiment des clients pour nous et
on y va
bon avant pour l'instant on y va
[Musique]
ça va
observez l'efficacité de la colle y
perdu
[Musique]
attention cette publicité a été réalisée
sans trucage
quand elle utilise je suis commandé à je
suis comme un fou
oui ça tourne c'est magique autour de
moi tout touche avait un il a cette
petite chose en plus qui fait que
lorsqu'ils l'utilisent
elle est inoubliable femmes douceur
charme tout à la basse et luxueux à moi
c'est shia vidéo
j'avais lol le fromage frigo vous
connaissez l'histoire des deux juifs qui
sont au bord de l'eau le premier dit au
second en mettant son doigt dans l'eau
qu'est ce qu'elle est froide
le second dit au premier mettant son nez
dans l'eau l'appel est profonde
[Rires]
une bonne nouvelle pour tous nos fans
les champignons des mecs y ont fait leur
apparition dans nos sous-bois français
n'oublient pas mille et une façon
surtout de les consommer
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on bouffe s'est demandé ce
qu'on vous fait découvrir ton petit
corps noir de nourrir ce corps de 1000
yards d'épater la gueule de madame tous
les jours en prime était content de
l'avoir l'école de madame tu me
supporter et moi j'ai supporté la
tiennent suffisamment longtemps
de gaulle et en plus je cueille
choque-t-il que de coller avec toi tu
veux qu'on parle quoi intellectuelle tu
veux qu'on arrive à avoir une discussion
tous les deux qu'est-ce que j'ai avec
toi j'ai de la merde toi j'ai rien rien
rien du tout tout en tentant pas n tout
en hargne une des goudes ma mère qu'elle
était content de l'avoir seulement
quelques dents c'est yves renaud mais je
suis quand même depuis que je viens avec
toi je deviens comme ma mère mes bras
[Musique]
l'efficacité de la colle hyper ghosn
attention cette publicité a également
été réalisée sans trucage
gisèle gisèle si je te revois une fois
que cet ouvrier la cette algérie ainsi
rachid si je te vois une foire et que
lui jeter ce quinté je lève ya pas de
papa et que je l'aimais
si je te revois une fois avec ce rachid
moi je te tue était un ouvrier 1
algérienne dans la famille me rendais
compte dans les soupes et les études
cheikh côtières pendant les qualifs
gisèle l'afrique
nous passerons
and on and on s'attache à vous que je
complète le recharger moi maintenant je
pense au fait si ma fille est plus
heureuse un coach et arabes c'est un
problème ils savent pas contre sauf
qu'il échappe à une grâce qui ne reflète
pas tout acheter aventure hier encore il
sera mal avec ça ça va pas continuer à
loger bien changé maintenant ma
philosophie c'est ça c'est plusieurs
trajets comme français mais tant mieux
je dis gisèle ventes sont pas heureuses
voilà la france est une grande et
bouchez des prix qui se mélangent
[Musique]
longtemps vous n'avez pas voulu parler
de votre vol c'était un sujet tabou
pourtant elle subit les altérations dus
à la pollution au foie et au temps qui
passe
un homme moderne s'occupe d'eux a pas
qu'au banane vient de m'appeler quand
toute une dernière
et de produits pour votre enfant chez
paco banane une nouvelle ligne de
maquillage pour que les hommes soient
toujours des hommes depuis le début de
l'histoire du cinéma
les dimensions de l'écran ont évolué le
format carré des films animés a été
remplacé rapidement car un format un peu
plus d'ambiance l'avènement du
cinémascope n'a pas favorisé il faut
bien le dire le rapprochement et la
complicité
quand ton super scope
dans ce conte très bientôt grâce à la
vidéo la création d'un format plus
vertical qui enfin rapprochera les
routes pour leur plus grand jour
[Musique]
défaillance sexuelle testé phorm le
traitement efficace pour retrouver votre
virilité de mal au début mais je vous
attends depuis cinq minutes quand
jean-marie je suis exténué nantes nous a
fait part je t'entends sinon peu plus en
plus les gens doivent venir ce soir à la
maison je suis une vraie passion
sexuelle encore et toujours
alors vous êtes un hélico dans des
appartements 30 avouent belle-maman en
piste et commerciaux mur est toujours
prête avec plaisir - oui des styles
forme a réellement changé notre fête
comment lui utilisait test iphone
[Musique]
bientôt mars 86 dans certaines
administrations les placards ont déjà
été nettoyé
[Musique]
le 1er mai sont deux dans l'eau et dit à
l'autre elle est froide
le second met son nez dans l'eau et dit
à l'autre
[Musique]
oui
de speak english abla espagnol par la
taille à nos vingt deux reprises deutsch
ta gueule là monsieur bonsoir voici
l'émission humoristique d'affaires 3 et
wii avec une première histoire
l'histoire de la seule émission qui
dérègle même votre téléviseur
mais je puis si on va mais madame au
procès dont vous étiez en quelle tenue
c'est comme ça gt non madame
alors vous vous étiez comme ça avait pas
de provocation de votre part et ça s'est
passé à quel endroit ça s'est passé
comme ça
non vous êtes gentil quand on vient
déposer d'écouté laisser placer un mot
quand on vient déposer une plainte
on a le nom de la rue où ça s'est passé
sont encore là on peut les arrive
d'accord vous allez prendre le nom de la
profession pour le match vous êtes
gentils une seconde non on vous a volé
de sa génération pour le match dans la
beauté et égalé dans le couloir de vous
arrêter une seconde monsieur est imposé
certains allez ça ne marchait pas bien
c'est gentil monsieur aussi a droit de
venir déposer une plate on est encore en
république
bon sang mais on n'a jamais montré en
salle ou pas vous allez avec moi je vous
propose de venir avec vous on va on va
repérer un petit peu les lieux madame
bon c'est fait vous alors vous voyez
coûté vous êtes gentils vous avez relevé
le nom de la rue et vous venez de me
déposer votre plein on va perdre du
temps avec ça c'est fait c'est fait
alors là on va aller voir sur place nos
invitations pour le match de ce soir de
ce sera les chiens
[Musique]
à
problème de fuite vous à confort vient
de mettre au point une nouvelle couche
avec france protectrice deux fois plus
efficace
problème de fuite n'hésitez pas vous à
confort
formidable nouvelle france productrice
amis lecteurs
mais sous les mémoires de l'ethnique à
l'histoire d'une caissière pas comme les
ouïes les grands noms écrivent
aujourd'hui des livres même les
speakerines écrivent leur mémoire ce qui
devait arriver arrive puisque les
caissières de grandes surfaces s'y
mettent aussi
et avec son livre est bien un autre ami
paul ethnique à des passe en ce moment
les ventes d'un livre
ce livre d'evelyne leclerc sur les
mémoires d'une speakerine paul et nika
pour vous présenter
je vais vous dire que vous êtes à vous
seuls dix ans de grandes surfaces
dix ans de supermarché ça commence
comment cette histoire fabuleuse ça
commnce un peu ma à l'âge de 14 ans oui
rencontre dans la rue monsieur grisou
lui-même chef de rayon supermarché
pétards juste à côté de chez moi qui me
dit vas-y ma petite paulette je pense
que tu as de l'arrière alors guère
marché il ya un moment savoureux un
moment à tout à fait incroyable quand
vous passez directement de la machine à
touches manuel à la caisse enregistreuse
automatique ça je peux dire que c'était
un moment fabuleux clash 27 jours c'est
la page 27 exactement entre la page 26
et la page et daniel c'était formidable
mais on n'a pas accepté comme ça un peu
bizarre de travail sur les manuels
passionne
la chronique il ya eu des contacts de
travail à vous excuser la rue provost et
s'il vous plaît ami policier
un récent décret du ministère vous
demande d'être encore plus courtois avec
les étrangers la rue beauvau mais
écoutez c'est la première grotte ça va
vous voyez allez-y qu'elle est
aujourd'hui encore l'article que vous
aimez bien avant riboud est pourquoi les
boules parce que la dynastie des ebooks
la princesse nardini mook est finalement
rentré au service du marquis de sade
mais le pinceau l'élu inquiet est sur
ses gardes
décide d'aller la chercher mais je crois
que j'arrive à temps un alors la voilà
la demeure du marquis de sade
des noix pour toi
demont
dis moi pourquoi tu mon souci
on va
de la vie
en vain
mais quand vient
[Musique]
matin
sourire
et où là
[Musique]
oh
jean
john a
[Musique]
e
la chanson
[Musique]
nadine la dénie book la bb montrond et
mes maîtres du genre dit tu vas te
changer tout de suite tu veux mettre ta
culotte rapide à aix et tu va nous
servir à table j'attends un invité
jean-marie koala navire lire des ebooks
je veux bien matraque et l'automatisme
il n'est pas du tout question que je
serve à table non je raconte pas le voir
et en plus tu wafa tu devenue commune
chic molle je m'ennuie avec toi mais je
préfère te donner ma démission je te
quitte lens je vais redevenir méchant
comme avant qu'ils écoutent bien su tout
de suite espèce de chien
je ne crois pas gérard et ollon nadine
jean jeu que je tenais bien je suis tout
de suite que tu fais ce que je fais là
on l'a échappé belle
je suis ce que c'est que le marquis de
padduc j'étais là c'est qu'ils
sympathique à la ccoim fatick n'a pas
fais et des culottes en latex et alors
on joue ta franchise en france en
battant l'as tu me suis bien c'est pas
facile en bas
[Musique]
à
dis maman
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
on dit d'un adolescent de l'âge ingrat
quand il a des boutons des rougeurs des
points noirs contre cela il existe des
pommades vous ne l'ignorez pas
maintenant les laboratoires claira zone
viennent de mettre au point une nouvelle
méthode efficace consulter directement
sur place
nos spécialistes merci claira zone
[Musique]
ça
des voix du nord
sow
nous sommes
m
joie
[Musique]
l'usap gestion de plomb
non
je ne sais pas
les guerres
some women aguero
[Musique]
sleeping mat héros
mais quelle est cette étrange et
mystérieux ballet mais oui c'est bien ça
et c'est une première
c'est l'inquiétant ballet des polices
parallèles
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
satisfaction pour jean paul clave tout
garçon un téléphone s'il vous plaît le
claf
ils sont nous qui était pas jours agités
bref ici vite et ça va mieux savais tu
vois c'est vrai clavier qui va mieux
mensonge je vais pouvoir briser sa
compagne chez les garçons machine à
calculer ce bouquet chéri et je crois
que c'est une bonne nouvelle
les chiffres sont en hausse comme le
week-end toute façon faut que je me suis
un garçon répondre au jt on a pris mon
talent moral en ce moment il faut que
j'aille là tu revois toujours cet brebis
galeuses la routine 19h45 déjà je suis
trop sous ça ne fait pas plaisir de
regarder une photo du clan perrine comme
autrefois
berson une photo du plan s'il vous plaît
c'était quand même le bon temps
garçon à café désolé madame permet à la
machine à café mais jamais rien de cette
maison
[Musique]
là
où les mineurs à chaque sortie d'un film
aux images plus bas reinfeldt au dos
attachmate pride du désir m
[Musique]
la ghetto
shu
bah
[Musique]
parra
[Applaudissements]
à
est évident qu'un jour on nous donne
l'électronique n'a pas été facile alors
de monstre que des semences de marcher à
côté de moi envie de rock de marineland
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
chers amis téléspectateurs bonjour 215e
jours de survie après ce que l'on a
appelé les trois ion du siècle ne perdez
pas courage et du fond de votre abri
répéter avec nous aujourd'hui irradiés
demain radio quelques nouvelles du front
que les villes d'orange et de salon sans
tomber hier soir après des combats
désespérés mais ne prétend pas quoi et
pour saper le moral
nous allons retrouver chantal qui va
nous aider le taux de ce week end
eh bien oui pas de météo aujourd'hui
pour les villes de cannes et
saint-raphaël qui ont été rayés de la
carte
hier soir par contre pour la journée une
surprise en effet nous attendions à
moins 50 degrés et nous aurons un moins
45 degrés cela grâce à un couloir de
fumée provoquée par l'explosion des
forages du sud
c'est donc une excellente nouvelle en
revanche les pluies radioactives
intégration de région
non pas mercredi mais je dis sachez vous
protéger le soleil aujourd'hui se lavera
à 16h20 mourir agissent
48 profiter un maximum et nous
souhaitons une très très bonne fête à
tous lancé le tableau rappelle le non
dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
commentaire est-ce que les entend on
vous aime d'armes et vous
[Applaudissements]
nous on a devant nous mais est-ce que
vous êtes également franchement
je ne vous entends pas mais ce que vous
m'entendez est ce que vous nous entendez
[Applaudissements]
de pau a mis à votre disposition pour
une somme modique des abris anti
atomiques à la première alerte
ayez le réflexe de pau
habitant de la région d'aix-en-provence
ce n'est pas le bombardement aérien hier
soir qui vous a irradié
mais bien l'explosion de la centrale
nucléaire de garrigue louer les
responsables de la sécurité doit sur en
nous disant que ce type d'accident ne
peut pas se reproduire dans les autres
centres mais mon dieu que le temps passe
lui et puis le temps passe et nous
allons la retrouver chantal chantal qui
est sur le terrain pour notre jeu le jeu
que nous attendons tous le jeu du
survivant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu la joie de vous retrouver pour
notre jeu du sourire en bourse elle fera
six candidats dont nous devons nous
trouver dans une ville qui était à
tenter une la moins de deux jours au
chercheur retrouver les survivants
il y en aura dix je ne sais pas en tout
cas je voudrais signaler à l'heureux
gagnant qu'il bénéficiera d'un voyage
paris-tokyo offertes par notre chaîne
évidemment et il paraît une compagnie
d'aviation force est là dedans tairai le
nom pour parfois publicité y at il des
survivants aujourd'hui nous avons savoir
tout de suite sur beugnot je vais les
appeler y at il des survivants ou par
toute autre branche sur paris
j'ai aperçu un survivant givet
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur survivants la tâche n'a
pas été trop dur tout va bien chez
l'automne c'est la mer oui je connais je
dis survivants ou alors c'est notre
vocation évidemment va être sur la
cuisine mon père du velouté de canard
aux pêches il faut évidemment incana et
des pêches mais il faut aussi une as
roma très particulière et exotique
laquelle le balsillie non monsieur je
vous donne encore une chance
réfléchissez mutunzi renfort bravo
monsieur s'il faut évidemment du canard
et des pêches il faut aussi un clou de
girofle ou l'impôt monsieur vous
connaissez évidemment notre épreuve
facultative je vous donne trois chiffres
leucate pour gagner le voyage paris
tokyo le 6 pour gagner la voiture et les
huit pour gagner à cocotte-minute le cas
choisissez vous monsieur je tends la
voiture numéro 6 ne prenez pas trop de
risques alors le 6 pour la boîte à aller
dit monsieur je vous en remercie
[Applaudissements]
ouah
la bonne chance effectivement ce sont
des choses qui arrivent dans notre grand
jeu là je me dépêchais de vous rendre
l'antenne parce que j'entends les
bombardiers à nouveau sur la ville
alors écoutez on se retrouve tout à
l'heure si vous le voulez bien pour la
suite de notre grand jeu des survivants
à tout à l'heure
et maintenant quelques instants de
détente avec la grande saga d'avant le
grand boum
voici la dynastie des kim
[Musique]
je chantais pour fasciner ahmed hajji
qui me désole
je chie
c'est des tickets d'alimentation vous en
avez assez des rations de nourriture que
l'armée vous distribuer tous les jours
et je vous comprends
edwige que dean auriez vous ce soir si
vous en aviez totalement le loisir et
bien charles henry je ferais exactement
la même chose qui hier mais je dînerai
avec
il
arroser
de vodka dans un nid de glace moi je
ferais plutôt pour du saumon de la
baltique avec un magret de canard du du
périgord je vous connais bien la gobbi
mer bourg b surtout que vous n'êtes vous
pas tenté par ses plats de rêve en ces
périodes de fêtes qui approchent une
race si vous voulez vous les procurer on
peut les parachutés et des prix seront
consentis
[Applaudissements]
demandez-lui mon général quels types de
bombes lambert
quel type de bande allez vous apporter
de chicago quel type de kits de bandes
arriveront autorités
[Musique]
vous devrez le cockpit est regardée
alors le temps et la relance or comme au
poker en général ce sont des ce sont des
ogives nucléaires
c'est bon c'est comme rentrer à la base
tout de suite demandé vous pourrez la
base de suite et bien chambéry
téléspectateurs voici la seconde partie
de notre grève de le jeu du survivant au
jeu si vous êtes très nombreux à suivre
cette émission et je dois préciser quand
même ce n'est pas facile de trouver tout
le temps les candidats
là on juge par une végétation à mon avis
il s'agit d'une bombe à neutrons qui
explosent et par ici parce que
franchement il ne reste presque plus
rien mais ce n'est pas grave je ne
désespère pas je suis même persuadé
pouvait très rapidement de nouveaux
candidats pour participer à ce grand jeu
ce grand jeu qui je vous le rappelle
permet quand même à ceux qui participent
de gagner un voyage paris tokyo offertes
par notre chaîne une compagnie
d'aviation dont je tairai le nom pour
quoi faire publicité voilà donc
j'attends les survivants je ne pense
qu'il m j'entends du bruit
en voici deux bonjour messieurs les sur
mille mois quelle joie de vous voir
franchement ce que nous appelons dans
notre jargon une défaillance technique
n'est vraiment pas grave parce que le
jeu du survivant en a vu d'autres et va
continuer évidemment il va continuer
dans un pour continuer puisque j'ai les
deux candidats qui sont allés sur un
papier pour vous poser une autre
question
messieurs comme un acte il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quartier général on ne vous entend
pas des crimes en général comme l'entend
pas on ne vous entend vous entend pas
[Musique]
vous allez faire vous allez
l'archéologie et rentrer à la base tout
de suite et plongez vous voulez
[Musique]
santé hygiène de vie
on nous annonce que le sida est en très
nette régression le rhume de cerveau
aussi merci les chercheurs continuez vos
recherches
grâce à vous la france grâce à vous la
france avance eh bien oui eh bien oui
bonsoir
n'oubliez pas d'être au rendez vous de
demain à n'oubliez pas non plus notre
devise
aujourd'hui irradiés demain radieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
cette semaine on n'avait pas bien le
moral mais rassurez vous la semaine
prochaine sera beaucoup mieux n'oubliez
pas pour autant d'autres devises
aujourd'hui radieux demain irradiés
[Musique]